Joe Biden's horror show on the border
just got a little more grisly on Monday
more than 50 illegal migrants were found
dead in a sweltering tractor trailer
abandoned near San Antonio they were
practically baked alive in the
oppressive Texas heat Smugglers tried to
cover up the rotting smell of the Dead
by sprinkling them with steak seasoning
and then they just ran away abandoning
the few people who were still left alive
they were children in that truck they
were families in that truck they were
smuggled by Coyotes due to Joe Biden's
broken border Governor Greg Abbott lays
the blame at the feet of our president
tweeting these deaths are on Biden they
are a result of his deadly open border
policies they show the deadly
consequences of his refusal to enforce
the law but Joe Biden says it's not his
fault saying this exploiting vulnerable
individuals for profit is shameful as is
political grandstanding around tragedy
and my Administration will continue to
do everything possible to stop human
Smugglers and traffickers
Joe Biden's doing everything possible to
stop Smugglers kind of like he's doing
everything possible to lower gas prices
which is nothing
joining me now is Texas governor Greg
Abbott
has the White House called you
um have have you heard from them about
this mass casualty event
absolutely not but I did see the
statement that was put up by Biden and
the thing that struck me is exactly what
you said and I want to elaborate he said
that he was doing everything possible to
stop human smuggling that's a lie they
he has stopped doing everything that had
been done to address human smuggling he
is defunded and
inadequately funded border patrol he's
dismantled ice he is eliminated all of
the border security efforts that were
put in place by President trump it was
just a year and a half ago when we had
the most secure Border in decades and
today we have a worse human smuggling
problem than ever before these people
who lost their lives they did so because
President Biden has empowered and
emboldened the cartels to do exactly
what you saw happen as a tragedy and
it's not going to stop until Biden
begins to enforce the laws passed by
Congress in the United States of the
cartels are getting richer than they
ever have before Governor have you heard
what the White House plan is to take out
the cartels do they have a plan to go on
offense against the cartels and the
coyotes
just so you the only thing that we've
seen is exactly what President Biden
campaigned on when he ran for president
he was quizzed during the debates if he
supported open borders and he said yes
and all he's done since he's been
president is employ open border policies
that means basically seeding the border
to the cartels to engage in activity
just like this these are not the only
people who have died coming across the
border this is just the most recent
example this happens all the time and
you're going to see the numbers
Skyrocket in the hot South Texas summer
that's setting in right now it's a
tragedy what President Biden is doing he
is knowingly allow this to happen as
well as what's happening with regard to
the infiltration of enough fentanyl to
kill every man woman and child in the
United States of America all right well
hopefully this President can be publicly
shamed into doing something more than
he's already doing
um we have our fingers crossed but we're
not expecting that to happen Governor
Abbott thanks so much for joining us
thank you Jesse hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else